me and Luke went to high school together
okay he was an offensive lineman he was
a senior when I was a freshman so I
played on the varsity as a backup
quarterback and then uh he was a senior
offensive lineman so
he didn't play much and I didn't play at
all
and so we would sit and talk to each
other on the sideline just kind of yeah
oh I've seen you guys I haven't seen
y'all but I've seen guys just like y'all
on TV it's like the guys who know
they're not going in so they're getting
really comfortable and they're really
digging in their heels and having a good
conversation like that's what we were
doing and so I always kind of was good
friends with him as much as you could be
from a freshman and a senior
and so he goes on to App State and uh my
dad died when I was really little so
when I turned 21 I was at Carolina I got
a secure Social Security so I got like I
think like I can't remember like 40 or
50 000 and just kind of hit my bank
account that gobbler yeah I got that
Goblin I had never had any money ever
and so I was just it was burning a hole
in my pocket I was like I gotta spin
this immediately I think I had to get
rid of this money and so I hit up Luke
I you know I was like what can I do this
I want to like invest it you know you're
21 you're like half a brain you're
trying to figure out a finance the rest
of your life make some huge business
move ask a 21 year old you know like
dude uh so I hit up Luke I was like and
he's making all these videos he's
singing at App State he's like on the
local TV I've never seen him in the
local team was he doing well at that
point he was just he wasn't doing
anything besides he was singing like the
local bar and he had a Facebook that's
when Facebook was big and he was posting
his videos
hear this incredible voice and I was
like bro you are gonna be you could be
something like you could you could be
something and hit him up I told him that
and Chase Rice went to high school too
and he was already doing it so we kind
of had that glimpse of you kind of just
had that glimpse of oh this could really
happen for somebody wow because Chase
had done it out of our out of our high
school and so I told Luke and I was like
man I would love to I got this money I'm
trying to blow basically and I was like
I would really like to uh
I would really like to like figure out a
situation like to invest in you in your
career dude because I think you're gonna
be like you could do something you just
need some money and he's like for what
you know but uh so anyways we're like
trying to talk about it we're like how
would it work and he's like let me send
you some songs I'm like working on and I
have the email exchange still and uh he
sends me like three songs
and I listened to him and I've got this
like cocky 21 year old I'm not being
cocky but you know you just think you
know everything and I'm like oh well you
know I don't know I send him back some
notes I was like I like this one but
maybe we could do this and
dude
uh anyway so he sent me three songs
long story short nothing ever happens
because it's impossible to just give
someone money and like what am I gonna
get like what if I got like 10 of his
career earnings I wouldn't be here I
know that but uh anyway so basically
fell through the cracks and I was
telling that story to somebody like uh a
couple years later I was like I'm gonna
go back and find those emails bro I went
back and by the way my notes were like
this song Maybe not it this song's
pretty good but maybe you could use a
dip bubble like an idiot don't know
anything about music never play the
instrument saying in my life and then uh
he probably thought I was an he
didn't say that he probably was like
this guy's a yeah I go back dude
all three records were number one
like when it rains it pours it was like
his first three number ones and it was
just sent him to me I was like yeah but
um
you're obviously not a good joke
dude I got the older I get the more I
have zero good qualities
zero good qualities
damn dude
can you imagine though if that would
have worked if I could have figured out
that business deal
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one